hey everyone it's sarah register nurse
rn.com and in this video i'm going to
talk about benzodiazepines versus
barbiturates
and as always whenever you get done
watching this youtube lecture you can
access the free quizzes that will test
you on this content
so let's get started first let's talk
about the similarities between
benzos and barbiturates so they are both
known for their sedative hypnotic
anxiolytic effects and they achieve this
by
depressing our central nervous system so
they're both known
as cns depressants now they can both
treat a wide variety of conditions some
are better at treating this
while some may be better at treating
that so in a nutshell
they both tend to treat anxiety seizures
insomnia
they are many times used before
procedures to help
calm a patient down relax them or use
during anesthesia
etc now the thing with benzos is that
they're used more to treat nowadays
anxiety and insomnia where barbiturates
they treated that more back in the day
but since benzos have came onto the
scene they tend to be a little bit safer
in these patients because with
barbiturates
they there's a risk of accidental
overdose because barbiturates have a
very small therapeutic index
where there is a small threshold between
the therapeutic dose
and the toxic dose so they were finding
a long time ago that there was a lot of
accidental overdoses
with barbiturates now there is a risk
of overdose with benzos they can
experience toxicity as well
but there is a lower risk with it
compared with the barbiturates due to
that low
threshold now both of these drugs they
enhance
the effects of the neurotransmitter gaba
which is gamma
aminobutyric acid so they enhance
how this inhibitory neurotransmitter
works in our body so whenever
it does its thing what we get is we get
a depressed central nervous system and
here in a second we'll quickly go over
the mechanism of
action both of these drugs act on the
gaba
a receptors in the body
the action of how they influence these
gaba a receptors
is the same because what they're going
to do whenever they bind
they're going to cause this channel to
open up
and gaba a receptors are known as
ligand-gated
receptors so whenever binding occurs you
get this channel that opens
up and chloride is going to go into the
cell and it's going to hyperpolarize it
and we're going to get that depressed
central nervous system because remember
gaba is an inhibitory neurotransmitter
but how they influence this
channel to work is a little bit
different
and we're going to talk about that in
our different differences here in a
moment
now with both of these drugs there is a
risk of dependence developing
along with addiction withdrawal and
tolerance
withdrawal happens whenever the patient
just abruptly quits
taking that and that's usually whenever
they've been taking this
long term and tolerance can develop with
both of these
again with long-term usage and this is
where they're no longer getting the same
effects from
that medication so they need a higher
dose
in order to achieve those same effects
that they were getting before
and with both of these you want to
definitely educate the patient that they
do not want to consume
any alcohol because it can definitely
increase the risk
of overdose and of course they don't
want to be taking any other types of cns
depressants so they wouldn't want to
be taking barbiturates and
benzodiazepines together that is
contraindicated now let's look at the
differences between
benzodiazepines and barbiturates so the
first thing
is how do you tell as a nurse if this
medication
is a barbiturate or a benzodiazepine
well you want to look at that generic
name so first benzodiazepine
most not all but most generic names tend
to end in pam
or lamb and if you look in the middle of
that generic name
most of them will have a z e or a z o
so look at the word benzodiazepine you
have a zo
and a ze and one of the generic drugs
that
follow that rule is like lorazepam now
with barbiturates
most of those tend to end in barbitol
and if you look at barbiturates you see
bar bit
so one of those drugs that follow that
rule is like phenobarbital
so hopefully that'll help you recognize
those drugs
now let's talk about their mechanism of
action i pointed out in similarities
that they influence the gaba a receptor
so let's talk about
their binding sites and how they
influence that channel
so here with this illustration i have
our neurotransmitter gaba hanging out
because we know
that these medications enhance the
neurotransmitter gaba
and then just for illustration purposes
i have barbiturates hanging out and i
have
benzos so first let's talk about
benzodiazepines
so we have our gaba a receptor and this
is a really cool receptor because it's
made up of five
subunits it has two beta subunits
two alpha and one gamma subunit
and since we're talking about benzos we
have
a binding site for the benzodiazepine
and it is found between the alpha and
the gamma
now we also on this gaba a receptor have
a binding site for the neurotransmitter
gaba and it's found between the alpha
and beta subunit
so whenever binding occurs with this
neurotransmitter gaba
and you have binding with benzo at its
site
what will happen here in the middle is
this channel that is found
this channel is going to open up and
chloride is going to enter in and it's
going to go down into the cell
and it's going to hyperpolarize it so
it's going to decrease
its firing potential because remember
gaba is an inhibitory
neurotransmitter so inhibits impedes
that message from being sent and so
we're going to
depress our central nervous system so
hence we're going to get
sedative hypnotic anxiolytic effects on
the body
now one key concept i want you to
remember is that benzodiazepines
increase how often this channel
opens up so it's going to do that now on
the flip side
let's look at barbiturates barbiturates
hanging out up here
so again we have the binding of our
neurotransmitter gaba at its site
and the barbiturate binding site is
found either on the alpha or the beta
subunit so it locks down bonds does its
thing
and it also causes that channel to open
up
so chloride is going to go in do the
same thing that it did over here it's
going to hyperpolarize that cell
now the difference that i want you to
remember is how it influenced that
channel
it's going to increase how long that
channel stays open so that channel
increases in this duration how long it
stays open
for chloride to flow through
hyperpolarize the cell over here with
benzos it was increasing
how often the channel opens so those are
two concepts you definitely want to keep
in mind
now one neat difference about
barbiturates that benzodiazepines
doesn't do
is that in high doses of barbiturates
they can actually influence this gaba a
receptor
and cause this channel to open without
the influence or the help of
the neurotransmitter gaba so
benzodiazepines cannot do that
now antidote how about if we have an
overdose because we learned
earlier that barbiturates have that
small
threshold so there's a higher risk of
overdose with those it can occur with
benzodiazepines as well
but it's a little less risk compared to
barbiturates
the thing with barbiturates is that if
an overdose does occur
there is not an antidote to reverse
effects the patient
has to be supported a lot of times they
will experience respiratory failure so
they'll need mechanical ventilation
sometimes dialysis can be used to remove
that
toxic medication from their blood or
activated charcoal now with
benzodiazepine
there is an antidote that you want to
remember it's called flamazanil
and this can be used to reverse the
effects of benzodiazepine
toxicity it needs to be used with
caution do the does the benefit
outweigh the risk involved so that's
something that the physician will have
to determine
okay now let's test your knowledge on
what we just learned by taking this quiz
question
our question says which cns suppressant
causes the chloride channel to stay
open longer is it a benzodiazepines or
b barbiturates and the answer is
b barbiturates because remember
barbiturates they increase how long this
channel stays open so we get more
chloride going through
into that cell which is going to hyper
polarize it and give us our depressed
central nervous system the
benzodiazepines they're just going to
increase how often that channel opens
now if you would like more free quiz
questions on this material you can
access the link in the youtube
description below and thank you so much
for watching